okay
the
topic today is orange tell your family
what does that mean it is your family
hopefully you went you got your siblings
your mom your dad your uncle your cousin
your grandparents your loved ones your
family your friends and we are gonna
talk today both about the legacy
financial system but also about bitcoin
and so let's start first with who the
hell am i well i do a couple of
different things one i spent the last
couple of years investing quite a bit of
money in the bitcoin and cryptocurrency
industry everything from bitcoin itself
to block fight coinbase etoro figure and
about a hundred other companies i've got
a podcast i write a daily letter to over
200 000 investors now and i previously
ran product and growth teams at facebook
and snapchat
and so when we think of
why this conversation is so important i
always start with what is the problem
the problem to me is uh the most
important place to start because if you
don't understand what the problem is
then the solution may not make sense and
so when we think of a problem really
what we're talking about is the state of
today's financial markets now pom what
the hell does that mean well first let's
start with the federal reserve and
central banking in general so for those
of you that don't know a central bank is
merely the national bank right it is
given the privilege to control the
production and distribution of money and
credit for a nation you can think of
this as the united states needs a bank
that bank is in charge of manipulating
controlling and also producing money and
the reason why that is important is
because it's only about 100 years old
the federal reserve is the central bank
in the united states
but it was only established in 1913 with
the passage of the federal reserve act
so we are talking about an organization
that is just over 100 years old that is
in charge of the production and
distribution of money and credit in the
u.s now that national bank that central
bank has a specific goal they are to
provide the country with a safe flexible
and stable monetary and financial system
that's it safe flexible and stable
monetary and financial system
and so since inception they've presided
over 16 economic recessions and also
their balance sheet has grown by almost
100 percent since march of 2020 and the
purchasing power of the u.s dollar since
1913 has fallen 96 which we'll get to in
a second but it's important to remember
that the central bank the federal
reserve of the united states has seen a
lot of things it has seen both good
times and bad times as that central bank
of the us and so ultimately when you
hear about the central bank and
decisions or meetings etc there's
something known as the federal open
market committee this is the fomc and
that is comprised of 12 individuals that
is right there's only 12 people that
make up this branch the federal reserve
system and they are responsible for the
formulation of monetary policy these 12
people although they have lots of people
on staff they listen to a lot of data
points and economists and all sorts of
forecasts there are 12 people in the u.s
that are responsible to come up with
monetary policy now that monetary policy
ends up affecting
over a hundred million people over 200
million over 300 million people 330
million americans that doesn't even
include the people who are non-americans
who also end up either holding using
transacting or trying to store value in
dollars so these 12 individuals have a
very very big responsibility they make
up that fomc which is ultimately part of
this central bank system given the
control of the production and
distribution of money and credit for the
us
now what they have been doing is no
secret so we have here on the left side
a quote from satoshi nakamoto the root
problem with conventional currency is
all the trust that's required to make it
work we have to trust that the central
banks are doing what they're supposed to
do the central bank must be trusted not
to debase the currency but the history
of fiat currencies is full of breaches
of that trust now what exactly does that
mean well if i have a dollar and let's
say i had that dollar 50 years ago that
dollar may be able to buy me five
coca-colas today one dollar doesn't buy
me five coca-colas it doesn't even buy
me one coca-cola it's not that the
coca-cola itself became more valuable
it's that the dollar itself has become
less valuable if something like the
dollar becomes less and less valuable
then you need more of them to buy the
same assets it's why you've probably
heard your parents or your grandparents
or your friends or family say real
estate always goes up well it's not so
much that the real estate itself is
becoming more valuable is that the
dollar is guaranteed to lose value over
time they're going to debase it devalue
the currency so what we see here is
we've got a chart this is not specific
to the federal reserve this happens with
all central banks this is their total
assets measured in trillions of dollars
you can see whether it's the federal
reserve the ecb the boj or the pboc they
all continue to increase their total
assets they continue to debase their
currencies and that ultimately means
that if you are sitting with dollars or
a fiat currency in your bank account you
end up having less and less purchasing
power your wealth is being devalued away
as you sit there and simply hold it
and so this brings up the idea of the
gold standard versus the fiat standard
now the gold standard is really
important to understand because the gold
standard is what we used to have before
1971 the entire monetary system was
backed by gold what does that mean well
if you go all the way back 5000 years
gold has served as money but ultimately
gold really really sucked to be able to
use in transactions it's heavy to carry
around it's really hard if i put it down
on a table and you need to actually
measure how much is there if i want to
break off a piece of it to give to kenny
or colton that's really difficult as
well so from a transaction standpoint
gold's horrible but it was a great store
of value and so ultimately in an attempt
to make gold more usable provide more
utility for it we created paper claims
on gold now those paper claims allowed
somebody to say i'm not going to carry
around my gold bars or my gold coins
anymore too heavy too hard to use i'm
instead going to leave them at a bank or
in a vault somewhere and i'm going to
carry around these pieces of paper and
these pieces of paper would allow me to
go and actually use them for
transactions so i can go to a general
store where i can go buy a horse back in
the day etc and i can say hey here's a
piece of paper that is a claim on my
gold that's sitting at a bank or in a
vault if you would like you can simply
hold on to the claim and use it for a
transaction yourself or you can actually
show up to the bank and turn in this
claim and they'll give you the gold so
now gold was able to hold value be a
store value but we had paper claims to
the gold and so the entire idea was that
countries agreed to convert paper money
into a fixed amount of gold on top of
that the united states used this gold
standard up until 1971 and gold was
valuable because it had sound money
principles all sound money principles
means is that it's outside of the system
and it was resistant to intentional
devaluation by others you couldn't
create more gold the only way to get
more gold was dig it up out of the
ground so in 1971 we transitioned from a
gold standard to the fiat standard now
it was originally presented to the
american people as a temporary
measurement but as we know one of the
surest ways to ensure a permanent
program is for the government to create
a temporary program and so the fiat
standard said well why don't we keep
using those paper claims but rather than
have the ability to actually turn them
in for gold what if we just use the
paper instead we don't actually need to
back it by gold anymore and so fiat
money which it the dollar is along with
things like the euro etc
is simply government issued currency not
backed by a physical commodity and it's
just issued and controlled by the
government so the central bank is able
to issue it they're able to control the
production and the distribution of the
money but that money is not backed by
anything it is just simply paper or an
electronic format and so this gives
central banks greater control over the
economy because now they can control how
much money is printed they don't need to
go dig up more gold in order to create
more dollars they can simply create it
by either pushing a button on a printing
press or now in the electronic world
they can just edit their bank account
just like you cannot go to your bank of
america or jpmorgan or chase et cetera
and say hey rather than have it a
thousand dollars i want to have ten
thousand dollars in my bank let me just
edit the number you can't do that but
they can do that they can simply edit
the number in their bank account and so
ultimately what we have seen is that
every fiat currency that has existed in
history has eventually failed there's
over 500 examples of this that they are
helpful in the short term they allow
people like last year march 2020 when
there are economic crisis that we can
respond to them by increasing the
monetary supply injecting capital into
the economy so there are positive side
effects to this but the long-term trend
is that every fiat currency in existence
has eventually failed and so if you go
back and you look this 20 bill was
redeemable in gold this is before we
ended the gold standard what you can see
here in the top is that on the actual
dollar bill itself it said redeemable in
gold on demand at the united states
treasury or in gold or lawful money at
any federal reserve bank this was the
ultimate manifestation of those paper
claims on gold the dollars were backed
by gold
you now look after the gold standard has
been removed it says this note is legal
tender for all debts public and private
there's no reference whatsoever to
actually being able to redeem these
dollars for gold or for any other
commodity so the top is the gold
standard the bottom is a fiat currency
and so what exactly happened since 1971.
well if you look on the left here what
we have is a
period of time called the great
prosperity and the entire idea can be
summed up with one sentence pay rose
with productivity what exactly does that
mean well it means that what you can see
on this chart is that as productivity of
workers and corporations etc went up so
did the pay that they received for that
and so wages and overall compensation
what continued to increase and they
tracked almost perfectly to the
increases in production but after 1971
once we went ahead and we unpegged the
dollar from gold we went on to the fiat
standard what we can see is that
productivity that top line continued
upwards it actually accelerated in terms
of how quickly it was growing but what
we see is the average hourly
compensation and the average hourly wage
the pay that actual workers received
went sideways and so we no longer saw
pay rising with productivity what that
means is in purchasing power terms
people started to get paid less and less
and less this is the feeling of i can't
get ahead i'm stuck in a rat race and so
what we have on the right side is the
purchasing power of the us dollar what
you can see is on the far left there you
can go all the way to 1913 the federal
reserve act creates a central bank with
the ability to manage the country's
money supply and what we have seen is we
have seen increases and decreases in
purchasing power but the long-term trend
is that we continue to see a
massive devaluation of the purchasing
power of u.s dollars along the bottom
you can see here what does one dollar
buy in 1913 one dollar would buy 30
hershey's chocolate bars the equivalent
of 26 dollars and 14 cents today in 1929
it was 10 rolls of toilet paper by 1933
it was 10 bottles of beer for one dollar
by 1953 it was 10 bags of pretzels by
1971 you could buy 17 oranges by 1997
you could buy four grapefruits 2008 two
lemons and today
up to
one dollar worth of a one small
mcdonald's coffee for a dollar and so
what we have seen is that the purchasing
power of the dollar continues to get
less and less valuable it's not that the
hershey's chocolate bars became more
valuable it's at the dollar lost
purchasing power and so ultimately this
is why the belief that savers end up
losing in today's economy is so true if
you simply spend less than you make take
your dollars and put them in your bank
account and you just let them sit there
there is a big big big chance that
you're going to just watch your
purchasing power actually be degraded
that means that you're going to have
less and less money from a purchasing
power standpoint if you have a hundred
dollars and let's say that a hundred
dollars could buy a single family home
today if you wait 20 years that hundred
dollars is not going to be able to buy
that same single family home it's not
because the house became more valuable
it's because the dollars became less
valuable and that is the erosion of
purchasing power many of your
grandparents and parents and friends
have told you all you have to do to get
to financial security is simply save
well that was true before 1971 but in
today's world the erosion of the
purchasing power of the us dollar means
that you can no longer do that you have
to learn what to do you have to convert
those dollars that are losing value into
something else in order to protect that
purchasing power
and so what we have here is the m2 money
stock and what we can see is that we
continue to just get an absolute
explosion
in what is occurring to money over 40
percent of the us dollars in circulation
were printed in the last 18 months
40
of all dollars in circulation created in
the last 18 months
there is a lot of ways to describe this
i simply describe it as absolutely
insane this is undisciplined monetary
and fiscal policy in a pure chart
and then obviously if you go ahead and
you look at cpi or inflation many of you
may not know what inflation actually is
but you feel it you see that gasoline is
up a lot you know when you go to the
grocery store your grocery bill is much
higher than it used to be you understand
that when you go and you try to pay your
electricity bill that's higher you see
that everything you go to the store to
purchase that's higher higher and higher
and you feel like you can't get ahead
that is inflation at work and so the cpi
the consumer price index simply
measures the average change over time
the price is paid by consumers for a
basket of goods and services the
official numbers are now 6.8 percent
from 12 months ago to the end of
november there was a 6.8
increase across the entire basket of
goods the average that we have seen over
the last decade or so was 2
or less so we now are trending at 3
times or more where we have been
recently there's an accelerated high
level of inflation and so there's many
many people who've been claiming that
inflation was transitory they were wrong
the federal reserve and many others now
have retired that word they're saying
this is not a transitory situation
inflation is here and it is likely to
stick around
now what many people don't know is the
way that they count inflation has
changed many times but the big big
change was in 1980 they actually changed
the calculation for inflation they no
longer simply say a loaf of bread was x
price last year and now it is y prints
instead they mess with the weightings in
the actual measurement they go ahead and
they change what they measure how they
measure and when they measure it simply
to try to continue to show a lower and
lower number they do not want to freak
people out
now if you were to go ahead and look at
unofficial numbers something here like
shadowstats which is a website this may
not be accurate in terms of the most
accurate representation but it is one of
many many examples that shows much
higher numbers so what this is showing
is that if you were to calculate this
based on the 1980 methodology we would
be having somewhere in the 13 to 14
official inflation numbers they had not
changed the methodology another one of
my great examples is that the official
cpi rent index they go ahead and they
measure rent in the united states they
are claiming that it is only up two
percent
two percent this year over the last 12
months but if you were to go and look at
something like zillow or apartment.com
or one of these websites that has
hundreds of millions of data points that
they measure in real time they are
showing anywhere between 8 to 15 percent
so if you actually dig into the
methodology of inflation the rent index
is a great example they are only
servicing they're only surveying they
literally ask people what do you pay in
rent what did you pay last year that
number is literally hundreds of
households at a time and it is
self-reported you tell them what the
change is they have no ability to
actually confirm the information and
they are only looking at a couple
hundred or thousand data points but if
you were to look at something like
zillow or apartment.com which actually
has the listings themselves has hundreds
of millions of data points across the
nation and has what i would consider a
more real-time accurate data set they're
showing numbers that are much much
higher than what we see in the official
numbers so inflation is high and the
real inflation is probably much higher
than what the official numbers are
actually telling us and then lastly if
we think global debt to gdp this is kind
of a high
level economic analysis but we've got a
quote here from greg foss on the right
when you have total global debt to gdp
at 400 percent
if you account for a three percent
discount rate global gdp needs to grow
at 12 just to outpace the interest
expense in this equation currency is the
error term we are in a debt spiral which
means the currency is guaranteed to
debase it is only mathematics many of
you probably remember that recently
politicians started to say we do not
raise the debt ceiling if we do not take
on more debt we will not be able to pay
our bills the united states will default
on their debt now of course the united
states has never defaulted before i
don't think that we will default because
we will just continue to raise the debt
ceiling more and more and more the kind
of layman's example would be if you had
a credit card and that credit card the
bill was due but you didn't have the
money to pay the credit card if instead
what the government does is they take
out a second credit card they take on
more debt to pay off the first debt they
continue to play this round-robin game
more and more and more borrowing simply
to pay off the old bills and so that is
unsustainable unless you run some sort
of balanced budget is nearly impossible
to do that forever
and so ultimately this brings us to
bitcoin if you remember the entire idea
of a central bank currency of the fiat
currencies that we have to trust that
the central bank and politicians are not
going to debase it when they debase the
currency they are stealing our
purchasing power that is where bitcoin
comes in
as many of you know bitcoin is a
decentralized digital currency that's it
it's decentralized no one owns it no one
controls it it's digital there is no
physical form there are not gold coins
although everyone always likes to show
the gold coin there is actually no gold
coins it is a digital currency and
obviously currency means that it serves
both as a store of value as a medium of
exchange and as a unit of account and so
what we have here is safety ammos who is
the author both the bitcoin standard and
the fiat standard so bitcoin represents
the first truly digital solution to the
problem of money and in it we find a
potential solution to the problems of
saleability soundness and sovereignty so
if we go ahead and we look what the hell
is making bitcoin so attractive to
people well the first is that it is
globally accessible anyone anywhere in
the world with an internet connection
does not matter who you are what
language you speak where you were born
who your parents are what your education
level is what your wealth status is what
you do for a living who you know or
where you live anyone with an internet
connection can simply go ahead and they
can buy sell or store it and they don't
need to ask permission from anyone this
is a decentralized system meaning that
there are no gatekeepers there is nobody
who says you may use it you may not use
is decentralized in nature and so when
you have a global population of billions
of people that now have access to a
global store of value that no one can
stop them from using it becomes very
interesting obviously in many countries
around the world people would like
dollars especially in countries where
their currency is failing if you look at
somewhere like venezuela or zimbabwe or
in places like turkey etc we know that
those people would love to have dollars
they believe in the full faith and
credit of the u.s government they want
dollars the problem is that it's very
hard to get dollars the accessibility of
dollars is low in those countries they
may actually have their dollars
confiscated if they sit in a bank
account it's expensive and also
dangerous to acquire dollars on the
black market so ultimately if people
have trouble getting dollars then this
global accessibility of a digital
currency becomes very interesting to
them the second thing the second feature
that people find interesting is this
idea of programmatic monetary policy now
the whole idea of monetary policy in the
united states is that those 12 people
fomc they come together they obviously
make decisions around monetary policy
they're able to actually affect interest
rates etc but what we know is that those
people they're human they can make
mistakes and they make variable
decisions variable meaning that
sometimes they actually do things that
make the currency more valuable or less
they strengthen it or they weaken it and
they are trying to respond to economic
situations but ultimately if people want
to trust the central bank we need it to
do two things the best central bank is
something that is predictable and
independent
independent meaning that it is not
subject to any sort of influence or
manipulation from outside sources
politicians cannot influence the
decision making and neither can anyone
else well there is nothing more
independent as a central bank than a
decentralized system one where there is
nobody no human or organization in
charge there's a programmatic monetary
policy meaning it is written into
software and that software executes
regardless of what goes on in the world
it does not care who is president does
not care what political party is in
control it does not care what you at
home think nor your neighbors or anyone
on the news it simply continues to
execute that software based on what was
written over 10 years ago the second
thing is that it is actually predictable
obviously if i asked you right now what
are the monetary policy decisions that
are going to be made over the next year
you don't know many people literally
watch from around the world they watch
these press conferences with the central
bankers and they try to see what color
is his tie did he use the word dovish or
not when somebody asked him a question
did he raise his eyebrows or not how
long was his speech and does that have
any correlation to future decision
making they're all trying to speculate
on what are these humans going to do in
the future the humans don't even know
what they're going to do in the future
and so ultimately people are finding it
very very valuable to have a
programmatic monetary policy something
that is predictable something that is
unchanged something that you can depend
on in something that no one controls
that programmatic monetary policy is a
180 degree difference than anything in
the fiat world
and so what is bitcoin's monetary policy
there will only ever be 21 million
bitcoin if i ask you how many dollars
there will be there's an infinite number
they can create as many of them as they
want they can create more and more and
more and more but with bitcoin there
will only ever be 21 million bitcoin in
the entire world that is set and cannot
be changed unless more than 51 percent
of people came together and agreed to
change it
every single day right now there are 900
new bitcoin that continue to come into
the circulating supply if i asked you
how many dollars were created nobody
knows if i asked you how many dollars
were created yesterday nobody knows if i
ask you how many dollars are going to be
created tomorrow nobody knows if i asked
you to show me transactions that
happened with dollars today nobody can
do it bitcoin is a transparent system it
is programmatic in nature i not only can
tell you that 900 bitcoin were created
today but i can go to a blockchain and i
can show you and verify it for you i can
prove it to you that only 900 bitcoin
were created today and put into the
circulating supply we now are at 18.8
million bitcoin in circulation so of the
21 million total there will ever be 18.8
are already in circulation we will
continue to get more and more bitcoin
coming into circulation every day until
we hit that 21 million total bitcoin now
this is important because ultimately in
a system in the legacy world where
nobody knows what the future decisions
are nobody knows what's happening right
now and nobody can even prove to you
what happened last week or last month or
last year they can simply tell you what
happened but they cannot prove it what
we have with the bitcoin system is full
transparency is audited every single day
hundreds of thousands of times by
millions of people everyone knows what
is happening and you can watch it in
real time you can prove it and you know
for certainty what will happen in the
future because you can actually read the
software and see what programmatically
will occur and so what are the
implications of this new monetary policy
well the first is that it has created
absolutely incredible attractive store
value and medium of exchange we have
watched bitcoin continue to rise in
global adoption if anyone is a student
of economics if you have a fixed supply
asset and demand increases then the
price has to increase in order to
accommodate everyone so that store of
value
compared to the dollar which allows your
purchasing power to be devalued over
time bitcoin has actually seen an
appreciation of purchasing power if you
sat with a hundred dollars in your bank
account ten years ago to today you can
buy less things with that hundred
dollars but if you had put one bitcoin
in your account and sat there one year
uh 10 years ago that one bitcoin would
have been worth somewhere around a
dollar or so but if you now fast forward
that one bitcoin can buy the equivalent
about 50 000
of items goods or services so your
purchasing power has increased with
bitcoin while your dollar purchasing
power has decreased is the exact
opposite of legacy system and so bitcoin
has become the best tool in the world to
preserve your purchasing power it is
defending your purchasing power that
decentralized network that cannot be
changed by any one individual or any one
organization will not allow for the
depreciation of your purchasing power
over long periods of time and that is
why millions and millions and millions
of people around the world continue to
find it attractive and so ultimately
bitcoin's the first store of value for
which its supply is entirely unaffected
by increased demand no matter how much
demand there is the bitcoin monetary
policy will not change if all the demand
went away tomorrow bitcoin's monetary
policy will not change if there is a
global pandemic bitcoin's monetary
policy will not change if there is world
war three bitcoin's monetary policy will
not change if you don't like bitcoin
bitcoin's monetary policy will not
change no matter what happens in the
world bitcoin will not change you can
watch it every single day you can audit
it and you can verify it and that is why
bitcoin has become the best tool in the
world to preserve your purchasing power
and so if you line up bitcoin with gold
and fiat currencies this is one of my
favorite things to show people is that
bitcoin is superior in every single
aspect except for one how long it has
been around so in terms of being able to
actually verify the supply and the
transactions etc bitcoin is superior to
the other two in terms of portability
how easy is it to actually move around
the world bitcoin is superior to gold
and fiat gold super heavy fiat we have
electronic money but it's not nearly as
good as bitcoin divisibility bitcoin is
super divisible gold and fiat are less
divisible scarcity bitcoin is way more
scarce than gold and fiat now
established history is interesting
because bitcoin has been around for
about 11 12 years gold has been around
for 5 000 years it is by far the longest
established history
fiat currency has only been around since
1971 so while bitcoin has only been
around for 11 or 12 years fiat currency
has only been around for about 50 years
so it's definitely been around for
longer than bitcoin but compared to gold
bitcoin and fiat have been around for
almost the same amount of time compared
to thousands and thousands of years of
history censorship resistance bitcoin is
much more compelling from that
standpoint programmable and
decentralized the same thing bitcoin is
superior to golden fiat in every single
aspect other than established history
where gold has survived for 5 000 plus
years and so there's tons and tons of
misconceptions about bitcoin everything
from it's not a viable currency well
there is trillions of dollars of
transactions in bitcoin this year that
have occurred and there are 100 plus
million people that hold it they use it
as a store values medium of exchange or
a unit of account it is a currency by
every single measurement
people say that bitcoin is slow but what
i always tell folks is i can walk into a
coffee shop you can stick your credit
card into the machine and in the seven
to ten seconds it takes for your credit
card to be read to be processed for to
tell you to remove your card and then
tell you that the transaction is
finished i can send bitcoin faster than
you can actually do your credit card
transaction by sticking your credit card
but of course when you stick that credit
card in you're not actually paying using
dollars you're paying using an iou
you still have to pay off the credit
card later with bitcoin when i make the
transaction there's cash finality the
merchant gets the money right then and
there i can't go home and cancel i can't
go and actually say you know what
someone stole my credit card and i
didn't actually pay for that item there
is no kind of chargeback or anything
else it is done when it is done people
say that bitcoin is volatile well like i
said 40 of us dollars have been created
in the last 18 months nobody thinks of
the dollar as volatile but the dollar
has been debased at a historic pace over
the last 18 months the reason is because
goods and services are priced in dollars
around you you don't think of the dollar
having an exchange price because you say
i have a hundred dollars and when i go
to the store the bread is priced as five
dollars so what i ultimately have to do
is i have to guess my purchasing power
increasing or decreasing i don't think
of the dollars having a price one dollar
equals one dollar well bitcoin is the
exact same thing if i go and i buy
something from kenny or colton and i
have five bitcoin and they say well you
want me to do that service then you have
to pay me one bitcoin then ultimately
there is no volatility one bitcoin
equals one bitcoin and that is where the
world is going is that people are
beginning on the internet specifically
this idea of an internet currency
they're beginning to price things in
bitcoin so that you can actually pay in
bitcoin and not worry about the
volatility people say it's a bubble well
if it was a bubble then it would burst
but ultimately bitcoin has been the best
performing asset over the last decade
and so this would be the craziest
longest bubble that's ever existed
obviously i don't think that that is
where most people think that we are
headed people will say that bitcoins
easy to hack if you think of the us
dollar system no one has ever hacked in
the federal reserve or the treasury but
there's been lots of hacks at banks
people have robbed banks they've hacked
into atms they've even went and robbed
armored trucks or they've hit people
over the head and stolen 20 out of their
pocket or out of their wallet
the further you get away from the
creation of the money the less secure it
becomes no one's ever hacked into the
federal reserve no one's ever hacked
into the treasury but they have
absolutely gone they've stolen it from
individuals they've broken into banks
they've broken into atms or armored
trucks same thing is true in bitcoin no
one has ever hacked the bitcoin
blockchain where the bitcoin is actually
created there's been plenty of hacks of
exchanges people have had their wallets
stolen there's been all sorts of other
types of nefarious activity but bitcoin
itself has never been hacked just like
there's never been a hack of the federal
reserve or the treasury it is in other
venues where people choose to store
their bitcoin that can be hacked that is
no different than the us dollar system
there's an argument that bitcoin is bad
for the environment what many people
don't know is that majority of the
energy consumption of bitcoin is
actually done with renewable energy what
we know is that the united states has
been the absolute biggest beneficiary of
the mining industry over the last 12
months or so and what we see is in
places like texas where bitcoin mining
now is about 10 of the total network
there are things like
gas flare capture what does that mean
one of the worst things for the
environment is that when they actually
go and they drill for oil there's a gas
that comes out of the earth and rather
than know what to do with it in many
cases they simply burn it into the
actual environment and so what
bitcoiners have figured out
is they go right to the wellhead they
actually capture the gas flare and they
take that and they turn it into power on
site and they mine bitcoin right there
so not only is bitcoin mining driving r
d of renewables and clean energy but
it's also helping to redivert bad things
that occur to the environment so bitcoin
is not bad for the environment i would
make a strong argument that bitcoin is
actually very good for the environment
and from a quantifiable standpoint you
can see that the impact it's having is
very positive bitcoin is not backed by
anything there's another misconception
right if you think of the dollar the
dollar is not backed by anything either
the best argument people have is it's
backed by the u.s government the u.s
military which is true to some degree
but bitcoin is actually backed by a
commodity the most valuable commodity in
the world today is not oil it is not
gold but it is computing power you think
about
computing power as a commodity bitcoin
is backed by that computing power the
bitcoin network is the strongest
computer network in the world it is the
most defensible computer network in the
world so bitcoin is backed by something
it's backed by computing power which is
the most valuable commodity in the
entire world that is why it's called a
digital currency
bitcoin is mostly used by criminals
another misconception
less than point five percent of all
transactions on the bitcoin network are
used for nefarious purposes the former
director of the cia came out with the
report
point four percent or less is nefarious
or criminal activity there are reports
out from places like the uk drug
administration that say well the us
dollar in fiat currencies over two
trillion dollars are laundered every
single year just with money laundering
there's bank after bank after bank
whether it's mexican drug cartels
whether it's some sort of terrorist
financing etc all that money laundering
continues to happen in u.s dollars
the choice currency of money launders
drug dealers and criminals around the
world is us dollars it is not bitcoin
you can easily put dollars in a duffel
bag and bring them somewhere and it is
completely untraceable but with bitcoin
every transaction happens on a public
ledger everyone in the world can see
that one bitcoin address sent a bitcoin
to another bitcoin address and it stays
there forever it can never be changed it
can never be hidden and so no matter how
long bitcoin lasts people always go back
and see that transaction so if you're a
criminal the idea of conducting your
crimes on a public ledger where anyone
can audit it law enforcement is watching
is pretty damn stupid that is why the
criminal use of bitcoin has
significantly decreased to now less than
0.5 percent of all transactions and
lastly the government will shut down
bitcoin well we've actually seen the
exact opposite in countries where
government has banned bitcoin what we've
seen is adoption has exploded in places
like nigeria and pakistan we've also
seen governments adopt bitcoin we know
that there's countries like el salvador
that not only are buying bitcoin that
are giving bitcoin to their citizens
that are setting up atm networks but
they're also mining bitcoin as well the
us government has already come forward
and there's multiple politicians
senators and congressmen that hold
bitcoin the major banks are
participating and actually either
conducting transactions holding bitcoin
or starting to actually service clients
with bitcoin we have public companies
like microstrategy square and tesla that
have bitcoin on their balance sheets and
what we know is that there is a very
very healthy appetite to continue to
usher bitcoin forward governments do not
want to stop bitcoin because ultimately
governments are going to need bitcoin
just as much as uri the governments
themselves they cannot continue the
masquerading of their debt they cannot
continue to devalue their own currencies
ultimately the governments need bitcoin
and so do organizations and so do
individuals they are not going to shut
this stuff down but over time we are
going to watch as we've already started
to see governments capitulate and start
to adopt bitcoin just as much as the
individuals
and so where ultimately is bitcoin today
it has grown from this crazy experiment
to a globally accepted digital currency
with over a trillion dollars in total
value and over 100 million users you can
see here that while that is incredible
incredible progress what we see is that
it is still smaller than a single
company like amazon the entire crypto
industry is only two two and a half
trillion dollars gold's 11 trillion the
us dollar m1 is 18.7 trillion treasury
bonds or 19 trillion and the u.s stock
market's 49 trillion dollars so
ultimately bitcoin while it has gone
from zero to a trillion in about 12
years it is minuscule in the entire
global financial system and when you go
ahead and you look the 10-year compound
annual growth rate of bitcoin has been
absolutely insane
the 10-year compound annual growth rate
of bitcoin is 173
that is nuts amazon coming in second
with 34
so bitcoin has been by far the single
best investment he could have made over
the last 10 years 173 percent compound
annual growth rate is very very very
impressive
and so ultimately if we go ahead and we
look at adoption itself what the hell is
going on with bitcoin adoption this
chart comes from the global macro
investor role paul
fantastically put together in the orange
we have the total crypto users measured
in millions in white we have the total
global the total global internet users
measured in millions between 1992 and
2006.
we have been growing about an 80
average annual growth since 2016 until
today we are somewhere in the 1997 1998
equivalent of bitcoin adoption compared
to that total global internet users but
the more important thing is not only
that we are growing and have already
gotten to 1997 or 1998 but that we are
going at a faster pace than what the
internet did now it makes sense the
bitcoin adoption is benefiting from so
many people having the internet so many
people having mobile phones etc you
would expect it to grow faster because
it's growing on the back of the internet
and ultimately what we will get is at
some point we will get a tapering off
you can't grow up into the right forever
so that 80 annual average yearly growth
is likely to go somewhere much lower
somewhere in the 30 35 percent 33
annual average growth that's okay
because at that point we will have over
a billion users already on board so this
adoption curve is really important to
understand it's growing incredibly quick
and what we know is if you looked at the
internet users in 1997 1998 extrapolated
out today there was still tons and tons
of growth to go that's what bitcoin has
in front of it so most people will ask
am i too late to bitcoin did i miss it
no of course not this is on the top left
eight years ago a post on reddit it said
too little too late honestly i feel like
i missed the boat when i first heard
about bitcoin 2009 2010 and it's
stressing me out to see all these
overnight fortunes being made i realize
there's still money to be made but
coming from someone who feels like a
check for 130 there's reason for
celebration 250 us dollars for one
bitcoin is a bit of a barrier of entry
for me i don't know why i'm posting here
frustration mixed with regret and
jealousy i guess i can't help but hate
myself for not knowing better this was
in 2015 literally somebody thinking that
they were actually before 2015. somebody
think they're too late to buy bitcoin at
a price of 250
per coin and so ultimately what we
continue to see was that bitcoin's price
is approximately
250x from what it was at that point of
250 dollars so if you believe bitcoin's
on a path to continue to be the world's
dominant store of value there is still
significant upside if a fixed supply
asset demand continues to increase then
ultimately the us dollar price the
exchange price has to go up in order to
accommodate everyone and so if you go
ahead and you compare it to all of these
other assets what you can see is that
bitcoin has only captured a small
percentage of these other types of store
of value bitcoin is
very very early in terms of comparison
to these other assets that people hold
to store value
and the most important thing is that
today bitcoin's trading somewhere around
50 000 should take 50 000 u.s dollars to
convert it to buy one full bitcoin but
you don't have to just buy one full
bitcoin you can buy a fraction of a
bitcoin each bitcoin is divisible into a
hundred million satoshi's that's similar
to a hundred cents make up one dollar
100 pennies make up a dollar 100 million
satoshi's make up one bitcoin so you
don't need to spend 50 or 60 000 in
order to start buying bitcoin you can
start off with as little as 50 cents if
you bought 10 worth of bitcoin at a
price of 60k per bitcoin you'd be able
to buy 16 000 satoshi's and that is
ultimately what people are doing is they
are simply continuing to just dollar
cost average into bitcoin or converting
their fiat currency into digital sound
money for about 600 or so today you can
become a satoshi millionaire and as the
value of the asset continues to increase
because of a fixed supply and increase
in demand then obviously those
million satoshis become more and more
valuable in u.s dollar terms so do not
forget that you can simply buy a
fraction of the bitcoin you have to buy
the full thing how do you do it there
are so many companies that you can go
and actually buy bitcoin on there are
regulated exchanges similar to if you
went to the stock market to a regulated
exchange you can go on places like
coinbase gemini block five strike etc
there's things like public market funds
so you can go and you can buy uh whether
it's gbtc or bitw et cetera there's also
futures based etfs now et cetera in the
us there's interest bearing accounts so
it's something like block file you can
buy bitcoin you can put the bitcoin in
an interest bearing account you can earn
some interest on that bitcoin and then
you can also buy bitcoin in your
retirement account via something like
kingdom trust which would allow you to
go in set up a self-directed ira
contribute dollars to it and then turn
around and convert that into bitcoin
this is why it is so valuable to
continue to get more and more ways for
people to get access to the asset
regulated exchanges public market funds
interest bearing accounts or retirement
accounts it all is available to the
individual today